cada vez son más los nombres que se
suman a la carrera para el liderazgo del
partido conservador británico y como
consecuencia para el puesto de primer
ministro al menos nueve tories han
confirmado su participación
la última es la secretaria de estado de
comercio penny moldón que competirá
contra una lista repleta de ministros
del gobierno de johnson por ejemplo
risis unac ex ministro de hacienda
listas ministra de relaciones exteriores
aunque todavía no ha hecho oficial su
candidatura
sayid jahvid que fue el ministro de
salud y ya buscó el liderazgo
conservador en 2019 nadim saharaui el
ministro de hacienda actual y dominik
graf vice primer ministro que ostenta la
carta de haber sido ya primer ministro
interino el proceso de elección empezará
formalmente cuando se reúna el comité
1922 que agrupa a todos los
conservadores sin cargos públicos su
comité ejecutivo fijará el calendario
para la elección del nuevo líder que
consiste en una serie de elecciones que
funcionan como rondas eliminatorias
hasta que sólo quedan 2 a tus finales
todo el proceso puede durar hasta seis
semanas o más lo que alargaría la
selección del sustituto de johnson y lo
mantendría como primer ministro hasta
inicios de otoño una situación que la
oposición laborista quiere evitar a toda
costa hasta el punto de plantear una
moción de censura para forzar su salida
sin embargo portavoces conservadores
fijaron el 20 de julio como el límite
para tener al menos a los dos candidatos
finalistas antes del receso de verano
del parlamento algo que podría ayudar a
acelerar el proceso